what's up everyone this is anthony pop
leone Oh most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off
[Music]
Charles hoskinson's is a Colorado based
technology entrepreneur and
mathematician and the current CEO of
input/output Hong Kong in this
conversation we discuss why he didn't
want to do an ICO what aetherium would
have become had it gone with a corporate
structure what he did once he left the
theory oh he gives an explanation of io
HK and Cardno and then we talk about
where we're going and what needs to
happen to get there I really enjoyed
this conversation and I hope you do as
well skirt school want to know who has
the best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother and mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
comm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mind it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm tell
them Tom sent you and thank me later as
many of you know crypto investors store
their digital assets on exchanges or in
cold storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help
them grow their investment holdings or
build overall wealth with the new block
by interest account users can now
securely store their Bitcoin or ether at
block 5 and receive 6% annual interest
paid monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pump again
that's block 5 comm / pump to sign up
and start earning crypto today if you
follow Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of e toriel
they're the world's number one social
trading platform and I love it they've
got more than 10 million other traders
that love it - and guess what they just
launched the united states eToro offers
access to the world's most popular
crypto currencies including Bitcoin
etherium and others with the smartest
trading tools and the ability to connect
with the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and using Taurus social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each row comm again that's eToro comm
get VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto
markets today Anthony pomp leon o is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of more Creek Digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I am here with
Charles himself
thanks so much for doing this thanks for
having me up we are recording at the
Wyoming bit coin and crypto conference
you've given a number of talks while
you've been here
Before we jump into all that though
let's get to your background
you've done a bunch of stuff mm-hmm what
was the first thing you did in Krypton
what'd you do before Krypton
before that okay what it wasn't
particularly good one but you know I did
a little bit of consulting a little bit
of programming and I was trying to find
my place in life I was kind of a nomad
so at one point I wanted to be a doctor
because my old my family does that my
brother's a doctor my dad's a doctor
your grandfather's a doctor but I don't
like people
so his kind of not a field you go into
if you're not a people person so I said
all right well if mathematics sounds fun
and I did that but I really didn't want
to climb the academic hierarchy it's one
of those like exercises and in
self-flagellation where you spend 10 15
years getting abused being completely
poor then you get tenure and you're like
yeah I have tenure now I can do whatever
I want and I'll still be paid little
amounts of money but I'll be a big fish
in a small tank so I that wasn't
particularly appealing but then I was
trying to figure out well what do i do
as a mathematician you know maybe I go
into finance maybe I'd be a developer or
whatever have you and I really really
liked things like Austrian economics and
so forth I'd worked on the wrong Paul
campaign back in 2007 and and so
suddenly that when Bitcoin came by I
said wow this thing's really cool and
this might be interesting but I didn't
think it was gonna work anybody would
adopt it cuz I was in very early in like
2011 people are still trading on
spreadsheets there were really stable
exchanges nobody was taking it seriously
so it was a fun thing to do it felt like
a club and yet another one of those
Austrian economic protest movements but
it wasn't a real movement then in 2013
that was kind of the bellwether year all
of a sudden all this money came in
Bitcoin hit a billion dollars and I said
wow this thing is probably here to stay
and it's gonna move really quickly so I
should do something problem is I didn't
know anybody I didn't really have any
job skills I'm not particularly good at
business especially back then so I said
alright well I remember what an old
professor told me he said those who
cannot do teach so what I did is I
created a free class called Bitcoin or
how I learned to stop worrying and Orlov
crypto so after you know dr. Strangelove
and I released it on udemy and I said
all right if anybody wants to sign up
sign up and I ended up getting over
80,000 students for that for the class
and how'd you market it I didn't it was
just viral I put it on Bitcoin talk and
the reddit and so forth and people just
shipped a link out and they'd send it to
friends and family and I met everybody
through that I met right
Erik Voorhees Andreas Antonopoulos and
back then nobody was really that
important and didn't really have a big
ego so they'd actually talk to you you
can send them you could send them emails
it also reminds me of Minecraft I was an
early adopter there and I used to send
emails to notch and he would reply back
and then after got really rich he'd stop
replying I said there's some sort of
relationship here between wealth and
power and access but anyway after I did
that one of my students was a Chinese
guy his name was Alicia aloud and he ran
a fund called BIP fund and he said hey I
love what you guys are doing I'll give
you half a million dollars to start
something I said well that's a terrible
idea I don't have a business plan I'm
not an entrepreneur I don't know how to
do any of this things oh I like the cut
of your jib you'll you'll figure it out
so I said alright well let me let me
pull my students and so I asked my
students if you had a half million
dollars what would you do and I got a
bimodal distribution between two answers
some group of people said stable coins
some group of people said decentralized
exchange so I said [ __ ] let's put them
both together and you know I'll create a
forum post on Bitcoin talk and see if
anybody's interested in this it's still
searchable it says project Invictus and
I had this mind map and I said I want to
do this as anybody interested ironically
the very first person who replied was
Dan Larimer one-bite master and this is
before anybody knew he was he was he was
working as a contract programmer at some
robotics company and he said I have this
crazy idea called bitshares and I said
well that looks interesting so I called
up Dan and we started emailing back and
forth and we eventually decided to set
up a company and we set up something
called Invictus innovations okay as the
ii/3 it was Invictus innovations
incorporate it was a Virginia company
and I flew I lived with Dan's father a
stand and his mom Pam and they had this
lovely little farm out and Floyd
Virginia was right next to Blacksburg
and for a few months I was working on
bitshares with Dan but boy we just
started fighting every day you know
really yeah oh god it was it was
miserable working with Tim and he
probably found it miserable working with
me see the Chinese investor we had said
hey there's this thing called an ICO we
should do that and I looked at it this
was back in 2013 pre etherium master
coin had just been done that was the
very first ICO and I said yeah
I don't know about that you know this
seems like a securities offering I don't
know and the Chinese were like yeah but
you guys to go do that say that you're
in Beijing right you'll get liquidity
and I have to deal with it we're in
Virginia in the backyard of the United
States so eventually we just couldn't
come to terms and I took a buyout and
then I moved on and meet when you and in
were disagreeing what were the
disagreements on I didn't want it I
didn't want to do a nice so it was
really nice yeah well I mean that was
one of the things the other thing was
the lack of rigor in the project cuz dan
has this habit of going from A to D and
you say what about B and C they said oh
don't worry about it that's already
that's a done deal and you're like well
no that's not how you design protocols
I've always been a guy who like we need
to do things in a peer-reviewed way in a
structured way we need to get
third-party validation these times he
said no that's not how this works we
need to be first to market we need a
momentum we need to you know just
release and if we screw something up we
can fix it yada yada yada so there was
just strategic disagreements and then
there's Direction disagreements and at
the end of the day his dad owned part of
the company he owned part of the couple
years to Larimer is one Hoskinson so I
mean I was I wasn't gonna win that and I
learned early on if if early in a
relationship you can't get along don't
try to drag it out and make it painful
for everybody just go yep so I took a
buyout and you know I got some Bitcoin
out of it and then I was kind of
unemployed for a little bit and Anthony
Diorio reached out to me and he said hey
for those that are listening we are at
the conference and we are in the room
right now and there's a baby and the
baby is very enthralled with the
conversation so it's letting you know
that that it's here yeah so anyway
Anthony reached out to me and at the
time he was ready to pick Quinn Alliance
at Canada and he knew me from my
education work that I had done and he
said hey can you create some educational
content for Bac
and I said sure so I started doing that
in about a month into it he said by the
way there's this really brilliant kid
and he gave me a white paper and I can't
make heads or tails about can you read
it let me know what you think about it
and I said sure I read the white paper
and it was aetherium it was a overlay
protocol on prank coin and Vitalik wrote
it and the talaq knew Anthony because
they both lived in Toronto and Vitalik
was going to a meetup group and
the decentral meetup group and anyway
after I read and I said there's a lot
missing but I think this could be
something great what are you guys doing
and he said well we have this informal
Skype meeting we're holding and there's
a few people in it if you if you want to
join it you're well more welcome and I
said sure so I was the fifth person to
join that meeting the other four were
Anthony Mihai Alesia Amir sheet read in
Vitalik himself so vitalik knew Amir
through collar coins he knew Mihai
because they started Bitcoin magazine
together and then he met Anthony from
from the central and so basically I came
in November December of 2013 and started
having conversations about how we should
structure it what we should do and
eventually just came to the conclusion
that the only way we were going to move
forward is if we all met each other so
Anthony said look we're speaking at the
North American Bitcoin conference in
January of 2014
I'll run a beach house and fly on down
and if you guys want to come come and
we'll see if we're [ __ ] and or if we
like each other and so we flew down
there and I could the rest is kind of
history in the space we we like each
other enough to try for it we left Miami
knowing that we had something very real
and very significant and there's really
kind of two factions that were there one
where the developer or open source he
factions the other was kind of the
business arm so in the business arm
there was a mirror and me hi and Anthony
and Joe Lubin and then the developer
side it was Jeff will G and Gavin and
Vitalik and I was kind of in the middle
of where I was sufficiently technical I
could talk to them and I had kind of
enough business sense where I could talk
to the business arm so I tried to keep
everything together and we had to make
kind of a philosophical decision about
what to do with the project and we call
it the crypto Google or the crypto
Mozilla question so basically do we
create a full profit take some VC money
go build a theorem and then release it
like Ripple or do we go and do an ICO
like master coin from a not-for-profit
organization so I made a very strong
argument for crypto Google I felt that
there weren't golden handcuffs and
financial incentives kind of all the
founders would scattered to the wind the
minute that that we became successful
and the project wouldn't have right
governance and there was a high
probability we just spent all the money
and it wouldn't work out so well and
initially everybody was on board with
that it was an eight to zero vote so no
no dissent
but it didn't sit right with Vitalik and
little by little he started thinking
about it the project kept getting bigger
and by the june of 2014 there were like
a hundred people that were doing various
things there's like a thousand people in
the sky proof so it was just too big so
we revisited that decision and vittala
decided unilaterally to go to Krypto
Mozilla and shortly thereafter like the
whole business arm got devastated so I'm
here and I left that day we got pushed
out and then shortly after Joe started
consensus and did his thing Anthony left
and started to Central and then the
developers started getting gutted so uh
Gavin created ëthe dev and eventually
parody tech and then Jeff started doing
video games so no one actually stayed so
we were both right you know he created a
tremendously successful product and and
I was right in that there wasn't an
incentive to stay but I guess it didn't
matter regardless what would have
happened a theorem if you had gone with
the corporate structure and everyone at
state what we were proposing was that we
would own a for-profit Swiss entity it
was called etherion Switzerland GmbH and
we would get some VC money centralize
the project there fill the protocol and
then release the protocol under our
foundation and do the ICO with a
finished product I felt the risk to
investors was significantly lower and
second if we were going to have
existential problems they would be occur
under the for-profit structure under
smart money so we would have less risk
of lawsuits and these types of things so
had we launched it we probably would
have looked a lot like ripple in that
respect the only difference being that
there would have been an ICO still and
it would have been done from a
foundation and there also would have
been a clear separation of concerns
between the founders and the custodians
who do the ICO if they would have been a
separate board that was truly
independent
so probably consensus and decentral
would have been rolled up into one
entity and we owned so maybe that would
have been a better model or maybe the
model that they chose was better it's
it's one of those what if games ya
really know when you left would you go
do next yeah so I was kind of the
hinterlands you know I was Owen - you
know bitshares didn't work out for me
and the theory hip didn't work out for
me at all everyone's like yeah maybe
this crypto thing isn't for you Charles
and I said okay maybe but I got invited
to do a TED talk and Bermuda and then I
said okay that'll be my my capstone no
I'll do my TED talk I'll leave the space
and the
go back into mathematics or something
who knows maybe I'll sell cars yes I
don't know you know so I I went to did
the TED talk and people liked it so much
that I started getting invitations to
speak at other locations and then my
somebody worked on me with on the
etherion project Jeremy would said hey
there's these guys in Japan that would
really like you to build a
cryptocurrency for him I said okay well
I don't have a company and you know I'm
just one guy and if we're gonna do that
you know it's like a serious deal we
have to kind of figure this out so I
flew out to Osaka Japan and then
basically Jeremy and I started talking
with these guys and we said fine let's
build a company so we formed IO HK we
formed it in early 2015 and basically
the idea would be that there's probably
gonna be a lot of money and a lot of
desire for crypto currencies but not a
lot of scientific or engineering talent
to service that money so if we built a
specialized firm that's kind of like a
factory for crypto currencies we'd
probably do pretty well and we basically
went and did that we got a contract and
started getting paid and then we started
hiring lots of scientists and lots of
engineers and we started working on
Cardno and it was really what got us
started I Oh HK yes what output
input/output Hong Kong where did that
name come from well input/output was
mostly just we've looked at crypto
currencies is like regulating the inputs
and outputs of society so we say okay
there's these new systems and you put
stuff and you get stuff out and we're
now in complete control of how commerce
society identity property rights are
going to work so we like the association
with kind of traditional engineering
things i/o is like an engineering term
right but we also like that
philosophical connection and Hong Kong
cuz you know we got an Asia contract and
we were in Asia and it was either
Singapore or Hong Kong and we went both
and we liked Hong Kong more and we
incorporated there we eventually left
Hong Kong we're you know we're pulling
assets out because of the geopolitics
and also because the Chinese
government's released following that
country but it was it was good for the
time and it was also a crypto Haven back
in 2015 there were a lot of crypto
businesses there got it and so you start
and you the first thing you build his
card on oh yeah and it was a high-risk
high-return project so basically we
structured it like a DARPA project we
said look if we're gonna build a crypto
currency
it's gotta be worth our time it's gotta
be worth the industry's time it's very
easy to fork Bitcoin or just take what
aetherium had done and it hadn't been
released at the time but there was a
test that we could have easily just
taking that like you know Tron did and
just put some stuff on it and said okay
we have a product now yeah and walked
away we said no if I'm gonna spend years
of my life doing something then let's do
it right so what we did is said okay if
a system was to scale to billions of
people and be useful for those people
and be really a financial operating
system for them so their whole financial
life lives in it from Securities and
commodities to currencies to their
identity to their land
then what would it have to have and we
identified three areas to go do some
research in so the first was scalability
and we said the system has to get faster
or stay at the same performance
regardless of how many users it has so
you gain user to get faster kinda like
BitTorrent you know when you download
Game of Thrones you hear really quickly
because a lot of people are doing it but
if you download pee-wee's Playhouse you
get it really slowly because there are a
few people download that ok then second
interoperability is a big deal because
at the end of the day there's gonna be
tons of these systems and if they can't
talk to each other it would almost be
like Wi-Fi where all your Samsung phone
can only connect to a Samsung router or
your Apple phone can only take an app or
router that would just be a terrible
user experience and Wi-Fi would be
useless to us but because we it's
ubiquitous and it's a standard we can
talk to each other it's now a very
useful thing to society so this is going
to be the same way these these systems
have to have protocols that allow you to
move information and value between them
and then finally sustainability that the
governance problem we have in the space
is normally products are curated by a
company or Federation companies so you
have the iPhone to apple or Windows to
Microsoft and so then there's that who
pays and who the size thing it's obvious
you say oh Microsoft is gonna pay and
they're gonna decide the future of
Windows great and if I have faith in
them I have faith in that product but
we're trying to make the argument that
these protocols are headless Vick Quinn
has no leader no controller but at the
same time we're trying to say that this
is a stable great platform to build your
business on and you know stake your
country's financial future on and you
say well if I don't really have an
explicit way of understanding how will
this protocol evolve or change and who
will pay for it then I run into two
problems one is the Golden Rule
he who has the gold makes the rules so
whoever's paying for it's probably have
a huge
of influence over the roadmap and that's
not probably not you second there's the
issue of well if we disagree we run into
like a Bitcoin pickle in cash type of
deal where you know suddenly the entire
ecosystem forks and now you have to
where there was one and you have to pick
sides and the minute you pick a side
then a you're a monster to the other
side you go from Bitcoin Jesus the
Bitcoin Judas and that's just really not
a good thing for the ecosystem so we
said if these are to be real and scale
to this many users we need to have
protocols that allow us to govern them
to pay for things to print money to pay
for things and to vote on improvement
proposals in a way that people are okay
with that reduce Forks so these were the
kind of three based philosophical
research goals and we started from first
principles so we said we're not gonna
assume anything proof of word proof of
stake blockchain not a blockchain
whatever we're just gonna do a bunch of
research so for the first two years of
the project 2015 2016 a little bit in
2017 it was just pure R&D pure research
we wrote tons of papers we did a
boatload of research into proof of stake
we learned a lot about all the the stuff
in the industry like we actually wrote a
formal mathematical definition for a
blockchain it's called the gkl 15 model
we just did all this stuff we also did a
lot of research into programming
languages because we looked at small
contracts we said these are kind of
necessary for the system to be useful
but then what makes a good smart
contract language what accounting system
should we use we formalized the UT of
sale system we proved the UT EXO systems
equivalent to aetherium style accounts
we did all this like broken window
fixing along the way then at the end of
that we said okay we have enough now to
actually pivot and go from a research
project to try to commercialize the
technology so then what we did is we
started gradually building up for
protocol and the first milestone was
just releasing in kind of a federated
mode similar to how ripple runs and just
use it to get exchange listings gets the
philosophy out there and tell people
what we're trying to do because no one
had heard of card on oh it was like did
no marketing at all so for two years we
were just silently sitting there and
everybody thought I was dead they're
like Charles Cod okay that no one
invited me to anything no one really
cared and then suddenly in 2017 we're
like oh yeah by the way we got this
protocol and here's all these papers and
I guess there's a hundred people working
here and all these scientists and
everything oh that's what he's been
doing for two years okay this is
interesting
so Cardinal released and immediately it
hit the top ten and
little while we were worth like thirty
billion dollars which was just batshit
crazy I was like guys we're in a bubble
this is bad for everybody and then he
brought a huge amount of people into the
ecosystem and then we were able to
leverage debt to learn a lot and then
all throughout 2018 we started actually
building the foundations of getting this
into to market as a fully decentralized
product so now we're in a position where
we're just about to release the Shelly
release which is turning over the system
from a federated state to a fully
decentralized state and there's just ton
of innovations we made the the proof of
stake protocol we have Wars it does
everything proof of work does you have a
bootstrap from Genesis property which
that basically means if you have
multiple chains you can pick the longest
chain the correct chain without a
checkpoint just like fit coin does we
operate a semi synchronous model just
like Bitcoin does were 50 percent
Byzantine tolerant just like Bitcoin is
so we systematically built up this
corpus of theory that matches the coin
security properties and we did it
through the peer review process it
wasn't trust Charles Hoskinson or his
scientists we wrote a paper we went to a
major academic conference that accepted
only 10 to 20% of the papers that were
submitted and they accepted the paper
euro [ __ ] CCS crypto and so forth so
there was like independent third party
validation that we're not saying crazy
things there's some reasonable merit
behind the things we're doing and what
was really nice about what we've
designed is the system is really
decentralized in fact at launch we can
have a thousand stake pools euro says 21
Bitcoin has four major mining operations
so you're looking at in a 50 to 250
times more decentralized than the
incumbents which is a you know a good
point the other thing is with or Wars
Hydra the protocol we're just about to
publish that's our charting protocol
when you have a lot of these guys they
do different work so you're no longer in
a replicated system your distributed
which means the system gets faster as
you get more participants which was one
of the original design goals we also
have a lot of other things like we
formalized side-chains it blew our mind
that blog stream didn't do this this was
their whole thing they're a seventy six
million dollars they got all these great
guys
we're like oh okay cool we'll just take
whatever block screams double modifier
to work for with us and that'll be great
then we looked in this like they don't
really do anything they said this was
her whole business model we're gonna
bring SCI change the Bitcoin and all the
innovation of the altcoin space will be
dragged into Bitcoin and Bitcoin will be
the one chain to rule them all
like great and then that never happened
so we had to actually write all the
theory out for her such ants we created
a paper called NEPA Powell's instance
for non interactive proofs a proof of
work then we created equivalent for that
for proof of stake and basically we
created a system where if I send you a
transaction from a foreign system I send
it with a proof and the proof does two
things one it proves that the coins are
real and two it proves the coins haven't
been double spent which is basically
what you need to do to be able to have
like clients or suchan's so we built a
whole corpus of theory and submitted a
lot of papers for that
so the bringing that into card on O and
then finally we just did a ton of PL
research which is why we're actually
here in Wyoming you know we thought
about smart contracts a lot and we
realized that at the end of the day
smart contracts probably aren't gonna be
a world computer that replaces
everything and just you know that we go
from Amazon now to aetherium and then we
run the whole app there the reality is
you're still probably a half server
client for a lot of these things but
what you're going to do is you're going
to take certain logic in your
application that causes your app to be
trusted pull that out and put it into a
blockchain
run that as a smart contract that's the
on chain code and the rest of the stuff
will run off chain on Amazon or Azure or
something like that so we design a
programming model that is very graceful
in that respect you write your off chain
and on chain code in the same source
file chain is Pascal or whatever
language you want eventually and then on
chain is Plutus and marlo or a dsl
that's for that particular application
whether it be a financial contract or a
supply chain contract or something so we
spent three years designing that with
some really good guys we hired the guy
who created the Haskell programming
language and this is now the place where
we're actually starting to show it off
and get developers to tell us what we
did wrong the good the bad the ugly you
know of that process what's next skirts
girl want to know who has the best URL
crypto comm that's right crypto comm
their crypto platform with one goal
mother mass adoption that's why we're
all here we're trying to get crypto in
every wallet crypto comm is helping
people do that through buying earning
lending and card payment everything you
could want at crypto comm go help your
boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto calm palms got you
always
to get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them pom sent you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block five and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pop again block 5 comm slash
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today what's
next well we got to get Shelley out and
that's all about decentralization and
that's a huge milestone unto itself it's
scary you know it's like having kids and
you raise them for a while and they live
with you and then they've gotten big
enough to get a bicycle and you're like
okay
please don't Kent run over by a car so
that's where we're at and we're just
about to release the network test net
this month and November we're releasing
the incentivize test net so people when
they stake they actually make real ADA
from that and then we'll get up to a
certain critical density of stake pools
and then once we're there we can fork
the main network and then the whole
network is being run by third parties
once we clear that and that's a huge
milestone very shortly thereafter we'll
roll smart contracts into the system
turn it on and then at that point it's
fully decentralize and it has smart
contracting capabilities so it's
basically like aetherium in that respect
but just more decentralize
a more performant but then the next step
is to turn on over bars Hydra where
those state pools now can shower the
ledger and then all of a sudden we get
very high TPS but the system there's
still a lot more to do on the network's
side and the storage layer to make it
truly scalable but that's a major
milestone for us and then the kind of
the last thing to do is put in the
governance stuff you know Tasos has been
a really big leader in the space in that
respect and dash has also been a leader
in this space of having the conversation
of what does it mean to participate in
vote whether they got it right or wrong
at least they had the courage to
actually go ahead and do something so
there's a lot there and we did write
some papers on this we wrote a liquid
democracy paper out of Lancaster
University Ben Chang Zhang is the one
who did that and we created kind of a
new voting system so we created a Carnot
Improvement proposal process and a
ballot system and roll the voting system
in and hopefully our community is able
to use that it's a big democratic
experiment for sure one of the things
that you've been talking a lot about
here at the conference is regulation and
the regulatory environment maybe talk a
little bit about what the issues you see
and kind of where we're going what needs
to happen there
well one of the biggest problems with
Bitcoin is it's blind deaf and dumb and
that was by design I and because if
you're doing an experiment you're
launching something you don't want to go
do 90 things right you know it's like
I'm gonna see if smoking causes cancer
and radioactive waste we're like well if
they get cancer it just tells you one or
the other or both are causing that right
or not our neither right so you want to
design an experiment where there's as
few variables as possible in a control
group so you can kind of see if what
your thesis is is true because a Bitcoin
it was well proof-of-work actually
resolved in a decentralized system and
well the token actually achieve value
these were the two core features of the
experiment but it never said okay we're
also going to build a system that is
able to replicate the world financial
system and also is fully compliant with
that system or capable with being
compliant this was not in scope so now
the F ATF and regulators and these other
guys are waking up and saying look we
like what you're doing and there's a lot
of merit here but you got to make
provisions for everybody else
like for example contingent settlement
so that's where a sends to be if and
only if XY and Z or whatever have
happened multi SiC is an example of that
you can only execute the transaction if
Alice and Bob and Jim signed the
transaction but you can have all kinds
of
contingencies so for my example imagine
you have a four not-for-profit and you
see anybody can donate to me as long as
they satisfy XY and Z so those are
contingencies for settlement so it would
be nice if he could bake that right into
the address that you present publicly
and the only way I can send you funds is
by satisfying those conditions maybe I
have to sign it with a unique identifier
maybe I have to sign a contract and hash
you know hash that and sign that and bet
that into the transaction saying I
consent to the donation deed all of
these types of things so that's a bread
and butter of all finance nobody just
sends you money for the sake of sending
you money they need there's always a
commercial story behind that then second
we have this situation where the
commerce is now divorced from the people
behind it so we don't really have a
notion of identity in these systems yet
we're trying to figure out how do we
install identity into these should this
be meta to the system so outside of the
system the problem is then that it
becomes malleable so you can swap it and
say oh that transaction actually
belonged to Charles it was actually Jim
but no we're gonna make his swap it make
it look like it was from you you'll get
any of the benefits the immutability the
time stamping the auditability
so there's a lot of arguments of saying
that these transactions they need to be
more than just push they also need to be
pull that need to have contingencies
they need to invent the story they need
to have provisions for identity they
need to be able to be smarter and have
contracts baked in and those may need to
be template able so that third parties
can come in and reverse transactions or
things like that it's a big conversation
and regulators are willing to have it
with us an example here in Wyoming
they're actually been very open but we
as an industry have to be willing to
have that conversation with them the
problem with maximalism is is that it
basically says there's one god one
gospel it is Satoshi as there's any
deviation from that vision then it's
wrong and everybody else is gonna have
to change to accommodate us it's a very
bad view and it doesn't cover things I
mean I can't even do pull payments with
Bitcoin and that's like half of commerce
right you find a sign up for a
subscription and every month Netflix
pulls out $9 or YouTube pulls out this
much money for you to Fred well that's
the bread and butter of most of our
commercial systems I can't even do that
with this system easily so you have to
concede that this is not necessarily a
fit for perfect
system and to say that I have to go off
chain to build these things as saying
now you have to centralize your solution
you don't solve your decentralized
reality in your decentralized dream by
by centralizing and I'm sorry that's
just philosophically incompatible so
what we're working on with Cardno is you
know now that we've built all these
capabilities and we have more than 40
papers we've written and half of them
been peer-reviewed we know the tech
works it's more of a question of how do
we steer this tech in the direction that
it's actually useful for people like if
for example your small Ethiopian
business that has a great cash flow and
you want to go and issue a security
token okay great
well you're going to live in a
regulatory environment so how do we
build a toolkit for you to do that where
you can comply with that regulatory
environment and then we go to the
Ethiopian government say hey we have
this capability can you just tell us if
it's legal or not and this is
essentially the idea of like taking the
law and writing it into code exactly
yeah exactly and then we as an industry
can actually have that conversation as
opposed to an individual basis so it'd
be great to collectively bargain I can
go to consensus and block stream and all
these other guys and we can all sit in a
room and say okay this is what we want
is an industry then we can collectively
goes in industry to the government say
we are willing to implement this into
code you just have to tell us if it's
right or wrong or make changes to it and
then we'll hey go for a while we'll come
to a compromise and then that code right
there is signed by the US government
suddenly you as an entrepreneur all you
have to do is say my smart contracts
have to inherit this requirement my
address has to have this contingency
built into it and now I'm in compliance
not my opinion is compliant I have
basically a no action letter effectively
from the US government you're doing this
you're okay I don't have to hire a
lawyer for that I don't have to hire an
accountant for that I I've completely
circumvented this whole legal industrial
complex that's formed to make people
satisfy these compliance regimes second
is super easy to globalize that because
then you just pick the countries you're
doing business with and you just put
them right into the structure of your
contract right in the structure of the
transaction
what's the Algerian standard what's the
Mongolian standard what's the French
standard click-click-click if my
customers coming from a new jurisdiction
I can't say oh that's a high-risk
customer high-risk jurisdiction you just
say let me just grab the contract and if
the customers willing to satisfy those
requirements then now that we're in full
clients and it cost me nothing as a
business to do that maybe my transaction
fee goes up by a penny or something
because there's a little extra
computation but we now have a global
system and if there's a problem with the
contract we just as an industry go and
fix it and we evolve from it we grow
from it but it's all cumulative and we
start converging to global standards as
opposed to this is fractured system
furthermore you don't get sued by the
regulator because you've established a
mens rea on an attempt to follow the law
and if they got it wrong we got it wrong
we fix it and then we just move on so I
think this is probably the single
greatest feature of what our industry is
doing is we're starting to realize that
we're living in a global business
environment but we have a very
fragmented most valiant notion of of how
karma should be and we're saying we now
have better tools to unify everybody and
get people to coordinating cooperate
with each other without giving up
sovereignty because you're not telling
Germany that they don't have to
correspond to and to be compatible with
Chinese law or US law you're saying you
get to decide what the standards are and
then I as an entrepreneur will now know
that up front and know how to comply
with that and then me and my customers
we have to sit down and make a decision
are we okay with that
for example if China does this they're
almost certainly going to put backdoors
in the system that will D anonymize
everything and potentially even give
them consoling ship over the assets so
then you will now know up front if you
do business in China this is what it's
going to be and then the global
marketplace will actually start making
decisions accordingly and say maybe I
don't want them to have that and so if
countries have boneheaded bad policy
instead of just us silently dealing with
it they actually start losing business
and they start losing money and the
global market will start collapsing down
on them and forcing them to change their
standard for sure one question I want to
ask before I finish up with some
rapid-fire questions is proof of work
first proof of stake you've seen many
variations you've been involved in a lot
of the more technical nuances of both
systems and those variations what's your
take today in terms of in the steady
state 10 20 years from now what we have
proof of work and proof of stake will
one be more dominant than the other
is there anything one variation that
you're
you know overly bullish on being kind of
that dominant one so with both protocols
you're trying to do the same thing so
you have three things you're trying to
do first you're trying to decide who's
in charge for for that particular period
of history I and then that person in
charge makes that block or makes that
update to the system and then the
network decides whether they've accepted
it or not so imagine a poker game you
have to decide who's the dealer and so
then the dealer is once selected will
deal the cards and then everybody looks
at the cards and collectively they make
a decision if they think the dealer's
cheated or not like if I pick up and I
have five aces I say well there's only
four on the deck so the dealer has done
something wrong and I recheck the dealer
or reject the block okay both systems
are legitimate both systems work we've
done an enormous amount of theoretical
work to prove that proof of stake is a
viable system if you accept its trade
offs okay the question is given that the
first step is super expensive with proof
of work and it's free for proof of stake
does that alone cause a tendency to push
into the proof of stake space and my
argument is no because it turns out that
that really expensive first step could
be potentially very useful so right now
we're just using useless algorithms well
you know we're whether it be a proc Pao
or you know the Bitcoin sha-256
algorithm or whatever they're useless
it's just digging holes and filling them
back up again but there are projects
like the perma coin paper in 2013 or
Chia or others that are actually looking
and saying can we create useful work or
for example we're creating an incentive
for people to store large amounts of
data or there's a paper actually as
title proof of useful work came out of
Berkeley that basically says if you
solve these puzzles you're solving
real-life problems and so instead of
saying we're just doing worthless stuff
you're now creating a marketplace for a
distributed computation and that's true
really valuable and right now if you
look at capacity a lot of businesses
exist from excess capacity you have a
car you only drive it so often maybe you
drive it a little bit more and drive
people around there's an uber you have a
house and you have a spare bedroom maybe
you rent it out and you have some
friends stay there or somebody stay
there class Airbnb right you have a
computer you're not using that laptop
it has excess capacity so if you have
all this computational equipment 99% of
the time you're not using it
well maybe you can monetize it through
these types of protocols and then
suddenly you now have the next
generation of proof of work so if we
move in that direction
I do think proof of work will stay if we
stay in the we're only doing this
because it's the only logical way to
select people that's just madness you
know I think proof of work cannot
survive in that kind of environment
especially given that there are so many
reasonably well established academics
whether they be Silvia McCauley with
al-quran' or what we've done with Ora
Boris or what we've seen with a lot of
the other proof estate protocols which
are academically verified peer reviewed
and there's mathematical proofs that
they do work and you say what are you
really trading off oh I might have to
trust a coalition of people at some
point in the future to create a check
point or something like that okay well
yeah you're trusting there's not a
backdoor and your computer chip or your
trusting is not a backdoor in your
operating system are you so
pathologically paranoid that you're
utterly unwilling to trust anyone or
even a group of people at some point to
upgrade the system or do something the
system or intervene in the system when
there's a problem meanwhile your entire
life is surrounded by people you trust
every day from the mechanic with your
car to these other types of things so I
think that if that's the only or in an
interview right now I'm recording I
think that if I think that if you know
if that's the only argument they have
that there's this absolute trust no one
just trust the protocol proof-of-work
doesn't stand a chance and how proof of
stick is just so much better from that
perspective and frankly Intune proof of
stake to have many different types of
trust parameters the other thing is
proof of work in its current
instantiation always federates there are
only four mining pools that control more
than 51% of the hash power and you
cannot play that game it's not a gala
terian it's a basically saying the
people have subsidized power people who
can afford data centers and the people
who could afford specialized Asics are
the ones who win and 99.99% of the you
of the world population is not in that
set of people so what you're doing is
saying it's a trustless protocol but the
curators of the system are not
we can never be me and will live in
jurisdictions that are so nice like
China or Kazakhstan or things like that
that that potentially could become very
problematic I just I just don't see the
logic in that so my whole argument is if
we find useful proof of work it will
stay it'll be more egalitarian and
democratic you'll be based on commodity
hardware that everybody has and it's a
capacity play like Airbnb or uber if we
can't find that then proof-of-work will
be completely replaced with proof of
steak style systems in the next five or
ten years got it what uh what do you
think is the most important company in
crypto other than your own well I'd say
it depends on your perspective if you're
talking about gaps
Dow's and the a smart contracts face the
bellwether they're the the significant
company is consensus they are just huge
company a lot of money a lot of people a
lot of stuff going on and they've made
massive and meaningful contributions
space were a competitor of theirs and
there are a lot of people consensus
really hate me and say horrible things
about me but I will give them their due
they've done great work in our industry
if you're talking about upcoming
exciting companies that are doing a
really good science al grand is
definitely one of them I have a lot of
respect for Sylvia McCauley I mean we
tend to forget this guy has the Nobel
Prize of computer science he has a
Turing award he's a tenured professor at
MIT and he's kind of dragging the whole
Club he's got the boys back together
it's like the Beatles are coming back
together and he's getting them
interested in our space and if he's
successful that's going to bring a lot
of horsepower on them to my chair side
into our industry so they're very
important I think there's a good
custodial role from block streams
perspective and they have been a very
effective vehicle of insuring people
that bitcoin is going to be around and
people are going to sustain and maintain
it so it's very important and Bitcoin
frankly is the brand of cryptocurrencies
you know we can't say oh well I'm gonna
succeed but bitcoin is gonna fail if
Bitcoin fails our whole industry is
probably in for a really bad time so I
agree with that yeah so we have to be we
have to be good to Bitcoin and blocks
turing has been they've done a lot of
cool things like beck 32 and simplicity
and
you know the the movement of sources to
make Bitcoin far more useful the push
for lightning you know these things are
good for Bitcoin I think and they allow
Bitcoin to at least be continued to be
competitive in its own right so I have a
lot of respect for them some of the
exchanges are very creative and very
innovative like finances always
innovative thing sometimes they pushing
the envelope a little too much but the
very least you have to say cz is a true
entrepreneur aranese trying to innovate
where and when he can so and yes I have
to have a lot of respect for coinbase of
being a Ned Flanders of our space no
they didn't piss anybody off they never
took the easy road out and what corn
place was able to do was legitimize
Bitcoin in our industry in ways that
many companies could not legitimize so I
have tremendous amount of respect for
them as well and I think they're always
going to be here until the IPO or get
acquired but they're profitable and they
do what they're going to do I also like
ledger a lot I think they've done some
great work on the trusted hardware side
of things and they've invited a
conversation about opening up the
possibility of what specialized devices
can do and right now they're a hardware
wallet but one day they could be
lightening node one day they can be a
trusted data feed for an Oracle there's
thousands of things you can do is
trusted hardware that's very magical so
to have well capitalized well run funded
companies that actually know how to ship
products that are high quality to the
consumer and work with us in the
industry because it's been a joy working
with ledger for their integration with
Coronado I have a lot of respect for
that and I have a lot of respect for any
entrepreneur who can do these things so
these are the kinds of companies that I
tend to like and it's more meritocratic
than whether they are pro aetherium or
pro card on o or pro charles or anti
charles it's just have we been able to
effectively work with them are they
making meaningful open source
contributions to the space are they
providing stability and support to our
industry as a whole these types of
criteria and the ones I've mentioned
another the Erik Voorhees with
shape-shift and what he's done there
Erik is just one of those transformative
guys he started as a frothing
libertarian anarchist who is like
Bitcoin is the only way and everything
else is garbage to the king of all coins
with shape-shift and it's just been a
really amazing transformation and he
kept his core but he also became a very
competent businessman along the
and he built very necessary
infrastructure for our space what's the
most important book you've ever read hmm
well the one that changed my perspective
probably the most was he of all her
Ahri's book sapiens and then the
follow-up book commodious because he he
basically said the whole world works on
narratives and it's one of those things
that once you know what you're looking
for a year you see it using wow that's
that's absolutely right I mean religion
economics all these things are just
social systems that were created to
stave off certain things so the old
order was or famine and disease and
these were just the Bane's of human
existence is the reason why the Four
Horseman represented these things you
know and the point of governments
religions in society was to basically
create a firewall to try to collectively
protect ourselves from this so all these
institutions these fictions we
constructed or to enable us to overcome
these challenges and as they died and we
no longer worry about starving to death
or a war killing us or disease killing
us then we have new challenges that come
which means that the fictions we
currently have the narratives we
currently have have to change so I
thought that that perspective was just
so incredibly valuable and another was
house of Morgan from Ron chernow Ron is
a great biographer he writes about
everybody whether it be george
washington or rockefeller and he does
these enormous ly in-depth things where
like when he wrote about george
washington he literally read every
letter this guy wrote he went found them
and washington was meticulous in
archiving them there was tens of
thousands of them and so the house of
Morgan was great because it really gave
a window into how the American financial
system got to where it's at
because there was just seriously no
entity no person no family that had more
influence on you as finance than JP
Morgan's family and it started from the
we're all a Ponzi scheme we're all scams
and this was back in the 1850s and 60s
when we were just an international joke
and you know nobody wanted to buy bonds
from the US because we don't default on
them you know we had no respect for it
the English were kind of running the
world financial system so if you wanted
to actually be a finance guy
yeah like Junius Morgan JP Morgan's
father you had to go to England and he
worked with George Peabody there but
then suddenly there was this pivot to
America especially after the Civil War
and it became clear the United States
was we're gonna become the world
financial system and we just kind of did
everything wrong we made every mistake
from the these giant trusts that people
formed in these transitive boards and
basically people reading the system so
they went to boiler rooms though things
and the Morgans in some way shape or
form had something to do with all of it
either from bailing out the US
government to getting the US government
into trouble they also were an extension
of u.s. foreign policy for the first
half of the 19th of the 20th century so
if we couldn't get into Mexico or the
Philippines or somewhere we get in
through a bank and so JP Morgan's guys
were probably somehow involved like Tom
Lamont and so forth so it was just an
eye-opening book and it really said wow
there's a lot more to this world
financial system and these guys were
touching it so highly highly recommend
that book just absolutely create another
one secrets of the temple it's a book
about the Federal Reserve System and
kind of where it came from and why it
operates it it's a little out of date in
the 80s and I really wish they had read
an update to it
anything from Niall Ferguson it's also
really good like the ascent of funny
money yeah yeah that's a great book to
read as well and I'm actually I have
some Medici blood in me so it was always
fun to to see that I say oh wow my
ancestors were interesting people and
they were quite innovative and quite
violent that's the same time so there we
go hopefully some other genetics have
bought it so we're along the way so I'd
highly recommend anything he has and
that's it that's certainly a lot of fun
but I read a lot of biographies and a
lot of history books and I that's what
tends to consume a lot of my time I also
tend to read about great failures like
the the latest one I just finished was
bad blood mm-hmm yeah and that's just a
great story of what happens when
groupthink yo comes into play you
Silicon Valley just wanted a female
entrepreneur to succeed and they have
all these models that they preach and
they tell me and everyone else to follow
and if you apply those very models to
Elizabeth Holmes it was an obvious scam
yet somehow she was able to sneak her
way into getting huge amounts of fun to
the game she knew the game and she knew
how to succeed within that game and it's
just a great lesson when you run a
business and you're in an industry that
tends to start having model ethic
thought that's where you always get into
trouble if you are saying the same
things that your competitors are saying
you believe the same things that all
your other people believe were doomed is
the whole point is to have diversity of
opinion and thought and you know
of different approaches and then the
market decides which ones are more
valuable and that changes over time and
if the valley just let her do this and
not only they let her do it she got
amazing people on her board like Henry
Kissinger and general mattis and so
forth these are people I couldn't talk
to and somehow she networked her way got
them to put their brand of reputation
into her system and what amazes me I
come from medical background my dad's a
doctor and you know very simple test you
say okay you're claiming that your magic
box can tell me things about my blood
great here's what I'm gonna do you have
your magic box sit in my office I'm I
don't need you to tell me how it works
I'm just gonna put ten blood samples
through this thing and we're gonna treat
it like a magician and you're not gonna
be able to move and go to a different
room or anything we're just gonna wait
around for the results and you're gonna
tell me what those 10 samples did and if
you got it right okay yeah you got
something now let's have a discussion
signed some non-disclosure to get it
done but if you're not willing to do
that well I don't care if it's magical
or not there's just no way to verify the
claims you're making her true I look the
same situation in our space with our
protocols like whether it be proof of
stake or this if all these people eight
hundred thousand TPS or this or that or
infinitely scalable they say these
things I say great write a paper a
scientific paper here's the conference
as you submit it to if they accept the
paper then I take you seriously it's not
elitism it's just to get there it's a
process and then we have something to
talk about I understand your trade-offs
I understand your approach I understand
your theory I kind of know where you're
coming from that I can't have a
conversation with you when you say
there's a wizard behind the curtain in
that Wizard is somehow gonna moderate or
control all these things and then and is
it's gonna make everything great you're
gonna get scammed 99.999% of the time
there is no wizard it's all made-up it's
all a scam all the way back to when
Benjamin Franklin was beaten by the
amazing Turk playing chess it was
actually a [ __ ] inside the machine
that was actually controlling it and
playing chess against him you know it
wasn't a robot though it sorry the 18th
century we didn't invent da horse right
but you know this is always the scam and
how they do these things so bad blood
was a great roll out of how that failure
occurred and I think every CEO every
decision-maker every VC every investor
should read that because that's a return
to real
and then when you get enthralled by
fabulous claims or enthralled by
fabulous proclamations of some
capability then you'll just be healthy
skepticism and say that might be true so
let's talk about the process upon which
we're going to jointly discover how
that's true and why that's true I'm not
giving up for that
before I end the podcast I always ask
about aliens ah believer non-believer
well you know there's the Fermi paradox
right and there's all these other every
mathematician brings up the Fermi
paradox yeah well yeah he trained to be
healthy skepticism statistically
speaking there's probably life in the
universe there's an open question of how
evolved and advanced it is and we're
certainly looking for and there's a lot
of indications that things things that
these aliens could exist it's one of
those things where we'll eventually get
to that juncture as a species either
we'll create it or we'll find it
actually if you ever watch the Joe Rogan
podcast he had Alex Jones on and man
that was a fun for our podcast but one
of the things Alex is firmly believes
now is that apparently there are
transdimensional aliens and the only way
to talk to them is to take large amounts
of DMT this which of course got which of
course got Joe really excited it's like
alright DMT we're finally talking about
that but I don't know you know this is
one of those things I'm not qualified to
talk about it's just it's a belief thing
so if I had to make a bet I'd say yes
have they visited us do they have a
relationship with us there's no evidence
of it that's credible but it doesn't
mean it's not the case yeah healthy
skepticism but probably true yeah you
pretty much articulated exactly how I
think about it mathematically very
likely but until we have the credible
evidence you know you sound a little
crazy if you go around saying that
aliens are out there right yeah the
transdimensional DMT Alex Jones alias
that's a great podcast to listen to
absolutely
all right well listen thank you so much
for doing this I know that there were a
little rushed for time but I think
people really enjoy this and it's super
interesting to hear kind of your story
and how you've got to where you are what
you're working on today so I have to do
it again in the future
Cheers hey everyone pop here if you like
this episode of off the chain and want
to help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain